[Music]
yep
yep we're doing it guys we're doing it
um hi hi hello
how was your we never really catch up no
we never go like hey girlfriend okay we
don't do the chat we don't do the chew
up front
let's chew for a second because i was
trying to think of what i could even
share i did stand up thrice this weekend
which was a thrill yeah thrice thrill
[ __ ] it was so cool
yeah it was not ideal one was on a truck
one was
both they were all in parking lots but
like
a [ __ ] thrill everything's a bringer
show
like does everything feel a little like
an open mic yeah but it's it's
kind of worse than that it's like an
open mic meets a fema
meetup it's not it's shitty it's it's
legit shitty but but you'll take it yeah
i don't
because i don't really need to
i just need to know if the joke's gonna
work right
i don't need to know like well it's
didn't get the full the tammy joe won
they were in par their cars right yes
but do people honk
these clackers so you say a thing
so you don't is it you but they laugh
and they clack
but is the clacking like is it feel a
little like pandering like yeah
they clack if they clack in lieu of
laughter because you can hear the
laughter
if your joke hit hits you can hear
laughter
if it's decent a good like
don't [ __ ] click don't click do you
think people were getting pity collects
just because like yay thank you for
being here yeah i think
they were i don't know what the rules
are by the way that
because i did a show in north hollywood
where people were outside in a parking
lot just
distanced and then the one
at the magic castle was in a parking lot
but everyone had to stay in their car
well there's no
live entertainment in l.a county so
but this is it's not illegal it's not i
mean it's like signed and
everything's i don't know maybe the car
thing is fine
yeah the fact that but the one where
just people distance
no oops you so people can't sit in a
park
there just can't be an organized live
entertainment
that's so odd i get it but it's like at
the store
they were doing it through the window
like people in the or in the window
and they got excited and then and they
got cited and they're like no live
comedy and no live entertainment at all
but it's like well they're far they
should have it but you
can't kill you can do the show you just
can't do that well
because then it'll expel more poison
from people's heads
um and i saw my niece
cute i always forget you have family i
know my niece is a therapist
oh she's old yeah i got older when you
say knees
i know the the 11. yeah yeah no she she
like flew here on her own
what'd you guys do stay with her i um
picked her up and then took her to best
buy to buy a camera for this
godforsaken podcast and then dropped her
off at brunch
that's nice pretty great what an uncle
i went to the beach okay
i love the beach and um
i went to the beach with some friends
and i kind of
i'm not gonna lie in corona i forget
what i did last week
like i forget like it's just like let's
just get through this
even though it's fine it's still like
okay well nothing i did a joke that's
not powerful enough for stand-up but i
said that
if you i said i was talking to a friend
of mine about like what i did today and
i was like i
showered and i went outside and walked
for a little bit and i uh
cooked for myself and i sound like a
paraplegic
i just sound like a parabola because
like i'm really making a full recovery
it's
it's this is not a life this is a
half-life yeah
this is it yeah um
okay so if you're watching on video
you're watching it as a clip
because uh guess what gang the full
episode thing
that you demanded it people don't like
them
they don't in terms of viewership clips
do
so much better than
full episodes and so we're just going to
start
doing clips now the here's why we're
going to do clips because they do better
and because this is a topical show
we record on monday right
we talk about the week before so
we're talking monday and we're going to
talk about something that happened last
tuesday
so in order if i don't wait to get this
material out
it's real stale i don't want to wait 10
days
to get out a thing about
you know the nba strike or whatever
because
you guys are not it's like you're sorry
man you can't
we're gonna have a separate full channel
this is now gonna be a clip channel so
if you want to on people were like well
i turned on my
my alerts my phone was blowing up with
all the alerts
but uh to either turn the alerts off
or we're gonna go back to releasing the
full episode
on thursday or friday okay will's gonna
start us
a new channel called
full how neal full how about that
and it'll be full episodes why don't you
just release the full
episodes on this channel on thursday
like we can but
that's i mean yeah we can't because
again because they're like
cause i'm there for the full they're
gonna find a way to complain they just
say
just say we don't even just be like on
it'll thursday or friday you'll get the
full episode yep on the video
okay and everything else if you're not
just know that
that's when it'll be there that's when
it's coming so if you don't want to turn
your if you want to turn your alerts off
we get it we're all adults here
but we bianca needs to make a living
from the podcast and by the way
uh look i'm do it you know i'm doing
fine
um by the way we the audio is the only
place we make actual money the video is
and by the way also releasing the video
hurt the audio so there's no advantage
to
us releasing the full video other than
that's how you like it
wait why is it releasing the video hurt
the audio because we released it
if we release audio on tuesday and video
on wednesday they don't need to
listen they don't need to get the audio
on two seconds wait for the video on
wednesday
the full episode we moved it up a day
but some people
don't audio some people only video okay
well most people only i know the amount
yeah most people audio yes i know the
amount
gang and guess what you're going to have
to wait your life i guess just got a
little bit worse
but the by the way the only don't be
condescending to them
well the way they talk they talk about
it like it's a it's a violation
we're talking about what five dudes in
the comments yes okay but they rep
must represent something right um we
represent yeah so they the only reason
they watch is see
you so you know what i mean but let's be
honest
most people don't watch so most people
don't realize how
hot i am so well
and neil does okay and i do i do a
pretty decent business
uh bianca how's the dick is for you oh
so good
um we need to we'll talk about that in a
little bit
so that's that's uh we're going to talk
about
because yeah we'll talk about it
so oh well now that you're here i might
as well say this on the air
you we don't need the time code on the
on the ins on the youtube video the time
stamps are good
no no oh sorry the stamps are good but i
don't need to know that if you advance
to
8 16 you'll get it they can just hit the
fast forward button
they just go to the next notch in the
thing
like in the description yeah i don't
need like
zero zero zero zero is the first thing
on our which is just looks bad
it has to be that in order to get the oh
[ __ ] these
face these youtubers don't know these
youtube [ __ ]
but we learned we all learned a lot
there this just became a tutorial at
this [ __ ]
by the way guys speaking of tutorial ken
sang the dp came the other day and
really hooked us up bianca's got some
real soft lighting
we put us uh we made this different we
put some uh
it's smooth frosting for the audio we
have a
set we built and the logo is lit up
in the middle of me anneal and um it
looks very nice
yes you can find that on how neil full
i'm kidding no we're all it's all going
to be the same
no full uh no full you want it all just
so everyone knows we're not going to do
a full channel because that's what
people are saying
do a separate clip channel on a full
channel who's saying this
that's how rogan does it so that's how
everybody's supposed to do it
right so joe's got and
and theo's uh i just feel like
everyone's subscribed to ours right now
so just tell they already know like
it'll be through bianca
they want a separate clip thing and a
separate
full thing that's what theo has that's
what joe has what everybody has
so i'm gonna give it to them with your
permission
despite the fact that you think you
don't that's not what they want i can
show you multiple comments
and that's like the way it's done now
well it's not that i just think that
there
are like you're saying the viewership
for the full
is not as much as for the clips or audio
so
we don't have like rogan's doing there
are people right but i love my feelers
but they're right now
what i'm saying is they want a debt they
don't want the alerts
so they're gonna get they can
unsubscribe to the clips
and they can subscribe to just the full
how neal full listen that's what they
want yes i'm telling you that just think
it's like
i'm just thinking it's easier but of
course not but you're you're not an
animal who
craves looking at video of bianca you'll
look at it every once in a while but you
know you're not a monster who needs to
see
they have an insatiable stinky
yes for luscious binky luscious pink
luscious pinky
guys you're not going to believe this
there was another shooting
in this country didn't have to do the
race yeah
um so they shot
jacob blake in the back for no reason
or no i'm sorry they had good reason he
said
hey i have a knife in the car so and
my three kids and knife just so you know
i have a knife in the car
and even if he got the knife
what did you think he was gonna do with
it cops
what did how how nice did you think he
was with the knives
right like he could have been bru
whoever the knight the king of the
knives is
it he could have been that nice and you
still could have shot him just wait
give it a second i'm not saying don't
you i'm just saying let him get then i
am saying don't you but i'm saying
let him get the knife let a problem
present itself and i understand
if you took our statements and put them
in certain situations
someone might die you know what i mean
i'm not saying that we're not saying
that
hey cops wait till they have the weapon
pointed at you
it's just that video it's such a perfect
angle of like
he posts no threat it's almost remember
the thing in highlights magazine goofy's
and gallant
i loved highlights yes i
it it's like highlights magazine for
racism
where it's like white people get this
treatment
and black people right get this straight
it's like so
bald where and it's
on they were nice about it they did it
on consecutive days
one on mond on sunday jacob blake gets
shot in the back and then on monday
kyle [ __ ] whatever his name
rittenhouse
walks with the cops who give him water
and walks past them when people are
going he just shot somebody
and he even was kind of like
surrendering because he thought all
right
and then they drove past them you're not
even like even look guys even for a
white person you gotta
really that was bad even for a white
person right he was like
he was he was a little blm for a split
second
yes he's just like they're not lock me
up gonna
yeah [ __ ] it yeah let me get i'm gonna
get out of town
yeah uh so they
it's so it's
it's it's cartoon it literally is
cartoonish it's just
it's like one thing and when a black
person does it
right and then there's all those videos
of white people
going the kid with the who like
has a gun and is running and the cops
chasing them like hey
like on some [ __ ] benny hill [ __ ]
right where the cops
it's just kind of fun yeah and he's like
you do it and then the cops like
because the cop might as well be going
like get get get
like on some [ __ ] dukes of hazzard
like what
[ __ ] and uh yeah
it's it's it's like it's un i can't i
you think they're kidding the funny
thing is for a long time you're like
well if this was like this they wouldn't
say it or if this was like this
everyone's a hypocrite this is proof
they're full of [ __ ] yeah there is no he
was a nice guy
and white people are treated differently
there are two sets of rules
there's the black rules and the white
rules we just have to start admitting it
well not us but but then i think okay
who gives a [ __ ] like we know we don't
actually need someone
it's like if you're an abusive
relationship and the prison be ecu and
they just won't take ownership and they
always blame you
yeah part of it would you make a
relationship you mean a
healthy good relationship go ahead fight
neil students
you mean most male female relationships
yep go ahead um
okay so at one point you really want
them like do you see how you're hurting
me
but let's say they just won't i mean
that doesn't
you aren't tethered to them you know you
really need to move on
for yourself and i think just
overall white america is not gonna
you know they're they have their own
divide you know and there's a portion of
white america that's does not matter
it they are never ever gonna get it
and the to the second point black people
are stuck here
black people cannot move on i was saying
to somebody
black americans should get
asylum everywhere i've said it here
black americans should get asylum in any
country they want
like hey i'm here and they're like what
country from
america oh and you're black yep come on
in that's as good as having
uh a civil war it's as bad as i mean
it's not as bad as like rwanda or
whatever but
it should allow you right to go to the
u.n
and go yeah this is this is inhumane
right we can all
it's just so funny because everything
the far right are crying far afraid of
claim is happening is literally
happening to black people
the everything that the tyranny that
they fee that that white
that the that the that the right uh the
conservative white people think that
government tyranny is
happening to black people and
through their actions they go oh we
don't care about that yeah it's like
well what did he
i remember i saw like there's a
conservative website i look at
and then i get upset and then i turn
just
like a cold shower cold rinse crypto
therapy
and those comments were like
uh blake was a vicious criminal
he thank god they shot him he was
vicious and i was just like
man anything what did they think his
charge was
people are there's a moth
um people were he has a third degree
sexual
sexual assault charge i don't know what
that is that's not
child rape i think it was a statutory
wheel and he's he's not a stand-up
comedian
let me get this straight up
what and who in their right mind would
get anyhow guys
no don't play it but just can you find
what his third degree sexual assault is
anyways eventually um but it's that
third degree sexual assault
i'm like yeah so
what does that have to do well the thing
that's the thing is any crime by a black
person
is death penalty
jaywalking well if he's black we're
we're going for the death penalty right
sinister black guy yeah we're going yeah
yeah it was funny those did you see the
meme about
how they had him cleaning graffiti
i was just like and then a couple
yesterday were
charles manson playing guitar at a
church
and um ted bundy doing the dishes yeah
which is [ __ ] bundy doing ted bundy
doing the dishes
he looks so wholesome like he's one of
the hottest he's a he's an eight
let's be honest i don't think he's
attractive at all when people are
interested i remember i had to go back
and look at ted benny like is this what
is this a white dude everyone's talking
about like can you pull up ted bundy
really quick
there's an over i wonder what the over
under head
ted bundy hot like he looks like a
creepy neighbor to me i don't understand
the ted bundy thing right how is he cute
wait what's cute about
that guy that's a good look i know
people you've dated that look like that
uh no
yes i do i don't want to name names no i
don't name names so he doesn't look like
that but anyways
uh i like that the guy below
to the left that's the security guard
from the michael jordan documentary
really it's not oh but it's well well
you know i love it look alike
um so we'll hopefully you'll do
something okay i guess it kind of looks
like ugly rob lowe there
yeah by the way did i tell you i refer
to myself as ugly roblox
as of a week ago because i'm aging well
and i'm like rob lowe except i'm ugly
you've actually used the terms yeah i
said i'm like an ugly rob i was on the
phone
i'm like an ugly roblox um roblo's like
60.
um so so his image
it's so many yeah and that so
i've decided i'm going to start
referring to
uh when i see bloods and crips
uh wearing red and blue plaid shirts i'm
going to start referring to them as
black lumberjacks because that's clearly
what they must
why they must be wearing this interface
they're lumberjacks
on their way to the forest to do some
jacking as it were um i need to read you
this
the did you see the times um
i mean it's not like the times is so
[ __ ] amazing but
this is the new york times no just like
the times the uk one time
they uh they literally
they wrote an article and this is how
they
categorize kyle
good old kyle um keep talking i'll pull
it up in a second
okay um so
he also uh
did you see the video of him punching a
girl and then the black
dude yeah are like we're gonna [ __ ] him
up
for punching a girl right which is
it it's another one of those cartoon
things
yeah it's like where you're like so
black dudes
saw him being [ __ ] up to a woman
and intervened
in the where there's other white men
there that were yeah
that were fine with it or fighting
fighting her
um and
you would think if i told you the
scenario of like black what
you would go well there's the so the
black guys must be bad guys right
wouldn't prove it
like no no actually the complete
opposite
that they were defending a woman against
this guy
and this guy whereas they the black guys
defend
women from kyle rittenhouse and kyle
rittenhouse defends
stores against black men
like okay this is like a [ __ ] fake
it's like an oh henry story where you're
like
this is not this is it's too convenient
i don't know how this better be amazing
this guy wrote this is the this
is the title of the incident that went
down in kenosha
a bullied teenager who revered the
police and
found purpose as a vigilante will appear
in court today
charged with murder after two people
were killed during
a night of unrest in wisconsin like
a bullied teenager who revered the
police and so
everything got somebody who bullied him
who [ __ ] knows
i don't know anything i never heard
about bullied maybe at the
anyway the girl that he that he beat up
she bullied him so they had to pull it
and they received all this backlash
because he was like
who wrote that some guy named like ben
while but it's like
someone that's like who's that's like to
me i'm like how much spin do you need
a vigilante yeah they don't and then
tucker carlson defending him and go like
are we surprised
craig it's by the way it's chandler
everybody he's chandler tucker crossing
king is chandler um are you really
surprised
monica that a white one boy took it
into his own hands um
yeah like that that's just it's another
thing
it's another cartoon bias like what
would the right wing
uh uh
uh blogosphere what would the press say
uh ann coulter said she wants to be your
president
just like that but here's the deal black
people aren't
welcome here no they're either tolerated
yes or they're unwelcome there's and
we are numb to it so i'm sure there's
people who are like
you guys are being a little dramatic
but i think we're not talking about it
in a day-by-day basis you know
not most people honestly like
getting pictures there's no signs that
say blacks this way
but there are sun downer towns that
wasn't that long ago
yeah and i knew that before i love
crafting
believe it or not um there's all this
[ __ ] where i'm like
we're not welcome we've just we're
black people are here so what are you
gonna do you know what i mean
but they're not welcome no they don't
you're
they're black people are not welcome and
the it's so [ __ ] up
because white people
made black people come it's not like
black people came here by
and why we're like hey get the [ __ ] out
of here white boy
they would have gladly laughed and pick
them up
kidnap them chain them up brought them
over here
and then we're like the [ __ ] are you
doing here and then we're like i hate
that you're here
yeah ooh that's skin [ __ ] you
invited me
you invited you more than invited me you
forced me to come here yeah but i just
wanted you to wait tables
right until that portion was over
imagine being it's like being invited to
someone's wedding and they're like
work yeah what did you think you were
gonna celebrate
yeah yeah that's we're both getting
close to the amount of because it's
complicated because it's like
they didn't invite them they kidnapped
them
if we yeah they okay kidnapped they
kidnapped that's thing the pup is the
kidnapper okay
they kidnap that's where white people
[ __ ] up the only mistake white people
met
uh they kidnapped black people brought
them to the wedding wedding
and the blind were like what am i doing
here and they're like [ __ ] first of
all
don't speak whatever language that is
you're speaking wedding language
and you're gonna wait tables and then
they do that
and then they realize like oh this is
wrong we can't
we don't want you to wait tables anymore
you're making me feel guilty
yes now i don't like that what i did
and yes i'm gonna put statues up um
uh so you know i was i was on reddit and
they were
it was the video of the two black dudes
like narrating the video of
him punching the girl and people so
many white people i wish that bla i will
say i wish the black dudes didn't say
we should piss the whip this
[ __ ] i like that part it's my
favorite
i liked it on the street but in terms of
like
a mass no come on look at what he was
doing no
like it's an eye for an eye problem it's
an eye for an eye problem
what people get used to that [ __ ] yes
it's an eye for an eye problem because
then then kyle rittenhouse sees them and
goes i'm gonna shoot these it's like
let's leave guns out of it just let's
restrain each other without guns
that's my only note oh is that you know
okay yeah um
so people were like a bunch of white
people were giving examples and one
someone wrote in the comments like yeah
there was a fight in a parking lot
and uh us and our friends drove in and
our friends in the other car were two
black dudes
and there was a huge fight so we just
pulled into the like uh the
whatever fast food parking lot and
waited it out
so when the fight was over and then cops
came
to break up the fight everyone scattered
they were
chilling in the car until everything was
cool i think i know what's gonna happen
i found the black people and they were
like get out of the car
yeah they were like we didn't do
anything and then all the workers and
other people were like they they just
pulled in
it's another one of those he beats up a
girl
the black guys go to stop it and then
the cops
get the black guys get in trouble the
cop
told the black kids attain them for like
an hour
put like a rest not arrested them but
like you know detain them sorry
and so after an hour was like you're
lucky these people stuck up for you or
else you would have been in a world of
[ __ ] i'm like
that and the black guy is lucky he's
lucky
because they're black people aren't
welcome they weren't welcome
no no you're not you're not welcome if
you do
nothing and you could lose your life at
any moment because someone doesn't like
you
you're welcome you're not welcome
you're you're like you said tolerate
even the word tolerance
the museum of tolerance i remember when
they opened the museum of tolerance i
was like
i don't love that word i think it's
pretty low
no i don't think it's about well i don't
know it's not about black people it's
jewish people but just the word
tolerance is like
couldn't do better i'm not the problem
is the
opposite of tolerance is like glorified
you know what i mean like
it shouldn't that's how racist people
are
is we had to build a museum to the idea
of tolerating jewish people yeah
[ __ ] crazy how racist people are
like i don't know if i'm gonna be able
to do it tolerate i don't know man
let me see it right let me see it all
right
i'll give it an hour and then they come
out and go like you know what
you know what i'm going to tolerate some
juice
i can do it now i've seen the light but
then now the guy who died
the guy who died in portland
he's the right-wing guy right-wing guy
who died
they're like he was there to he was a
medic
i'm like dude maybe maybe he had
something going on but it was from out
of state
and i just find it funny that when the
protests happened
in late may early june everybody from
out of state
was a white antifa agitator out of state
agitator stay out go back to where you
came from and now these
people like online they
they make they make caravans to go into
these places just to agitate
and everybody makes an excuse for them
so you could also make a case
that black americans
deserve in israel
that's what i always say the the only um
reparation should be
a place that they won't get killed give
them land just
and guess what if you took away even the
land that wasn't even being
used but if you took it away even if you
were the problem then the
any it'll what happened with is
again yes well you don't take away like
that there's plenty of acres there's
nobody
good not good land not like anywhere
anyone wants to be
right well in america you you can at
least pay them for what you take
everybody's gonna have a problem with it
you can give him like west texas or
something i mean
like do you know how many texas people
are gonna be like
ch chick give us west eggs tens of
thousands
what's going on in west texas well i'm
saying that's a big area
right and that i had a thought earlier
which is
it's odd that white
white people loathe black people so much
that
white people even like native americans
like that [ __ ] like wounded knee and
then there's white militia people
defending
they say that like these natives got
violated
and you're don't tread on me they side
with the natives in that one
right and like the wounded knee but as
soon as blackberry and they're like well
that's part of the game right that's
just gonna happen i mean that's you
gotta
every yeah the death penalty what'd you
do yeah um
it's it's so deep
it's so deep because
we were like slaves and although my
slaves went to
my my family slaves mm-hmm went to la
[Music]
well can you do like weed smoke fake
weed
graphics that's so [ __ ] stupid
it's amazing i just like that it's like
a music
like as if they just well because what
happens is the damn people got to run to
the dance floor
i know when they hear it a regular music
when they know that it's coming
um i just oh well
that was so fun i forgot i know that
your people can't
it's the how deep how deep racism is how
deep is your love for me
yeah cisco it's just how deep is your
racism like how much
if you the problem is black people are
slaves and that
i don't i think there's something
psychological that
no one can get past no one knows how to
figure out to
get past the the shame of it
and then the guilt and then the lower
class and everything like how do we get
past that
immigrants coming here and being
mistreated is different than
you were a slave and we yeah
everything's good
thing you will get hazed out of it
irish immigrants italian immigrants yeah
you get out you get hazed out you get
like [ __ ] clean
yeah mexicans are dealing with any
central american south central south
american people any
that group latinos get
[ __ ] clean up yeah you want to be in
this frat you [ __ ]
you scrub floors for 20 years and then
you
grab you matriculate up um you know i
did that
that harvard iranian speech remember
they emailed you
and i didn't it was about like
anti-blackness and iranian diaspora but
it was also just about
how do you speak to immigrants about
black lives matter because immigrants
are not
team black people and my point was like
the problem is that they come here and
they don't know the language
and they don't know the culture they
don't know the customs they don't know
anything and they can
somehow carve out some sort of financial
independence i love this
matter what the [ __ ] is you have
everything like
and i the thing is i understand that
fully and i i suggested
tell them imagine if that one they
wouldn't even be coming to america it
was
on the backs of blacks that made this
country in like a position for economic
prosperity but whatever
just tell them like imagine i feel like
that point of view is too esoteric for
white people
for most people like if it weren't for
it it's like ah it's too mad it's two
then okay the next step is like imagine
so iranians came especially to la in
like the
seventh the late 70s right and i was
like okay imagine if a bunch of romans
came here
and you know they had they they were met
with prejudice and
but they carved out like a community and
then imagine if someone just bombed that
community
just took it away bombed it killed your
people and then you
poisoned it over prosecuted it arrested
half the people
no real justice for you you just have to
kind of go away live in tents
find something else and then whoever
survived that massacre
moved to another state and then the same
thing happened
and then there was rapes killing babies
taken away
no justice no education no funding and
then every time you tried to climb
up the prosperity louder someone just
shoved you off
every time how many times would it take
till you just stay down
yeah but i don't even think that that's
the that has to
more to do with black psychology i'm
talking about not black
that sounds like the staying down thing
sounds like what that
repeated oppression does what i'm saying
is when uh when
like immigrant diaspora come here and
they look at black people like
what you have everything why are you
you watch this yeah it's like it's like
yeah but you know different but
yeah and the when you tell someone well
you don't understand they're like
i every immigrant has a really shitty
legitimately shitty story
that it's like sweep yeah clean yeah
like use that
so it's hard for them to get the
psychology of being
beat down for a sentence yeah because
because you because it's
cartoonishly it's you wouldn't believe
it yeah
you wouldn't believe it if that happened
you just wouldn't
and i think if i if you even told some
immigrant parents that they still
wouldn't believe you
no that's because it's
it's so cruel it's you couldn't
it's i mean i have a thought like maybe
black people need to wear body cams
just i i don't know what else because
the cops won't turn theirs on
so give them to black people and let
them wear them
do you know what i mean like there's got
to be some
recourse protocol for when you approach
a black person like let's just admit it
like
hey turn on your phone camera please
ma'am i'm going to approach
the car cool just have it be
let's just do it it doesn't happen who's
saying that the cops the cops should be
like
i'm going to approach you can you please
turn on your camera i can't be trusted
and they would never i know what i'm
like
i need you to turn you need to keep me
honest
you need to keep me honest i can't help
i'm almost shooting you right now
if i'm honest that's how i can't i don't
even know what's happened something's
overcoming me
right uh something needs to
change like i we keep saying that but
body cam
when i thought when body cams got
implemented i was like this will help
and then they just turn them off well
it's like okay then why do you they
can't turn them off
they cannot be allowed to turn them off
they should just be going and going yes
there's
there's like a nester yeah my nest
records you'd
cost 10 a month but you know what's
funny is that there was an incident in
north hollywood
in north hollywood where someone was
like there's a man with a gun somewhere
on the streets so they just saw a black
guy running
maybe 10 minutes later well that must
have been the guy with the gun then
i think shoot him out shoot him now and
then ask questions like the guy takes
out
the ar-15 in his car and across
and just like murders him in front of
the school
and they go and they don't there's no
medical and it all
and they all turn they kept saying
they're like okay turn off your body cam
yeah you can hear you can hear it one
guy didn't turn off his body again
and nothing it's still nothing's
happened so
even when you see the proof i mean like
it's it's something else has to change
that's just
a band-aid on a symptom it has to start
before the body can
you're talking about a hundred year
process
um honestly i mean i will definitely be
dead by then
well not if i not with this vegan diet
doctor savvy
have you seen the pills i've gotten
you've seen the pills packing first of
all with
solar ray a sponsor
um uh yeah you're not
it's go to freevitamind.com um
the uh the yeah i i will be dead but
guess who else will be dead
a lot of innocent black people for no
[ __ ] reason i don't get the killing
part i i
be prejudicing everything why are we
feeling very crime
is punishable by the death penalty in
white eyes
it's such a fake christian nation it's
just like we i just i don't get the
disconnect in this country this is the
most hypocritical full of [ __ ]
doesn't know who it is country it's like
we want to be this
like i even the things the far right is
saying i'm like
you're going against your own principles
like you're that you don't like
anti-fascists they don't
it's i did a daily show about it they
don't
yeah i'm against anti-fascists well you
know what that means you're four
means you're four fascists just if you
quickly
double negative take those away negative
for that
cancel out four and pro tifa
every you're pro your protein that's so
funny protein
sometimes i used to write for tv every
once in a while
but everything that's fascist is what
they're against
yes but because it's it's fine
if you do it to the browns
these browns don't count yes it's
they're not
full numeric so i would say three-fifths
is
still about what white people think they
are it's like four
fifths now yeah like lebron
yeah lebron gets a four and then it's
like ooh that one fifth is like shut up
and dribble
yeah dave's the four fifths
congratulations
uh a couple people rihanna beyonce jay-z
they get to they got their extra fifth
take your fifth
there should be a ceremony like a gold
record like we present you with another
fifth of citizenship it basically is for
celebrities
yeah that's what it's like chris is like
the being a being a
uh fame is the greatest gift god can
give a black man
because you just become a white person
unless
you're not a special
yes then you actually go to two-fifths
now you're below everyone yes
uh because it's like we loved you you
hear me chris brown
um he like he became like below
[ __ ] he was never above with white
people though he was getting there
almost there he was you know what's odd
though he's like
six-fifths with black women somehow with
a
young black woman yeah he's [ __ ]
great looking and dances tits off and
he's a great singer
i have a chris brown concert d and
i just i can't wear it
you're very nice well it just it feels
like what the [ __ ] you
beat up women i just you know but at the
same time
i feel like white america is so harsh on
black men even when they make the same
mistake
so it's like you feel like a traitor
both yes that's the thing with
r kelly and bill cosby and they go why
do black people defend them
because they're not going to just hand
them over to white people because they
know that they're not going to get
a fair trial even with millions of
dollars they're still
bill cosby got to four fifths and like a
half
there's some though that just that have
floated away from the black community
it's like
stacey dash you can have her haven't
done candace owens
yeah but they were never bill cosby was
nine tenths and look what he had to do
stacy dash was she was all she did was
[ __ ] b-list black movies oh
no but she didn't clueless that's how
white people know her yeah
um so
i [ __ ] i don't know how to resolve it
it's unresolvable that's what they call
an unresolvable segment
and that is the end of this clip
the rnc big sinkers dude
did you watch it i watched
trump's lullaby
lullaby
hey yeah yeah dude what's her face gold
foil
good guy guy
joe cub you know what that was like i
meant to put this on instagram
that was the white lady version of
the speech from the warriors where the
guy goes
can you dig it it was the white lady
version of can you dig it
so bad you hear me suckers
i just want to know who coached her
because someone told her that was good
someone told her that was a good idea it
was the
it was the i think mar did the
observation that it was the white
version
it was the democrat liberal uh
republican version of yeah the of the
howard dean screaming oh yeah
it was like the white there was the
republican version of that
it's the it's someone who's not used to
dealing
just public speak it's public speaking
you can't hit those notes
without a response yeah if you go up
there you
sound like a lunatic with that
like
like you can't you're just left with
nothing
they should have played cued music yes
it's it's a
fireworks cue yeah pony just some
something explode
turn it over turn it over
unleash the hound yes pyro it but she
didn't she had nothing
but the rest of it i didn't really
it was it was like it's just they're all
very corny
events yeah just really coin events but
somehow the republican
side it's always a bit cornier because
republicans uh there was a study
there should be a segment called they
did a study yeah uh let's if
hey um somebody eric johnson
yeah eric johnson we need a song called
they did a study and keep it eric
johnson keep it
you know how we need it you know how we
like it put all the eric johnson touches
in there
little pre little pre-chorus little echo
chorus
and then degrade um as only you can
uh they like symbolism they love
symbols they love uh
institutions it's i think we've talked
about it
conservative that's they want they like
a franchise
yes conserve how have things been
right let's keep it that way whereas
liberals
can uh are progressive it's progress i
can let's make some progress
on the way we've done it yeah we've done
it that way let's do it differently
don't let the gays get married
yes what's this you know what i mean
um yeah it's healthcare whatever so they
love
the americana and it's the same
boring [ __ ] though yeah it's been the
same boring [ __ ] since like the
50s it's like i feel like those are the
people that go
see fast and furious remakes or just
like
those same old remakes or the sequels
the sequel sorry
who's i think you're underestimating oh
do you want to know who's seeing fast
furious movies
[ __ ] latino men i love it
i mean latino dudes love it that's who's
saying it
because i'll tell you why tell me i peep
this
when i saw the trailer for the first
fast and furious
uh producer named neil moritz
um the brownest
basis cast of a movie ever there's
paul walker's the only like white
person in the movie and look where it
got him
um paul but you know what i mean like
paul walker is the only
it's all it's all beige khaki
black uh latino there's no
just like white people so if you're a
brown
person who is
you know not doesn't isn't uh didn't go
to an ivy league school
and car movies work internationally as i
think we've also talked about
because you don't need to speak english
to understand
flag uh [ __ ]
foot hitting gas pedal uh
black car white car hey now the black
car's in front
and the guy is driving and he's like i'm
going to beat you to that
other flag it's [ __ ] a baby can
understand it yeah
so count your money right
count your money over and over and
apparently they're just i've never seen
any
people thought i heard the seventh one
was very good
nonce i don't like if the seventh one is
great i'm not watching it
yes um there's so many other things
yeah that's like uh a joke that i tried
one time
about when people go like
when a series starts slow right like
look
it's a little slow by the seventh
episode um
that's like saying to somebody like i
want you to meet my friend steve and i
want you guys to drive
from new york to chicago from new york
to chicago
you're not gonna like them right but i
need you to get past that i was like dog
if i don't like them after [ __ ] 12
hours it's not gonna happen and i'm not
giving that much leeway to a tv show
right that's like like the wire took me
three episodes
the wires the only the wires of course
the wire
that's i'm not gonna say it's built that
way but
that's there's something happens in the
third or fourth episode of the first
season where you're like
something just got in me right like
i i see these people as my family
and i need them to live and be okay i
need
barksdale yeah yes but
yeah so that's the exception but um
i don't oh uh symbolism american but
that's the same thing
foot on pedal steering wheel right for
the eyes
like instant you just go up i get it i
get it i get it i put it on mute and i
was like
i don't actually need to unmute it no
you can watch it on plane
it's literally it's
you don't need to speak english
foreigners love it
um i did it was funny because i was
listening to
s not like i think i did c-span i didn't
do it through like cnn i did it
through another channel and they just
had a live feed
after the last after trump spoke
and he walked away with melania uh and
then he just was like
live feed camera on the lawn and all
these people talking
and i was like what the hell and then it
was auto-generated um
captions it was so fascinating it was
they had the sound on the sound people
were like oh yeah let me give you my
number it's seven five
i was like this is i was there no one
was watching it after a while but i was
watching it
and i was like what was it on c span or
something it was on
some feeds it was a feat and it was just
like it was above where he was talking
so it was just
on the the camera of the lawn shot
and it was just like a it looked like a
security cam it was so
funny it was so funny how many people
like kellyanne conway
there were so many people waiting to
take photos with her and
you could see it was just the whole
thing what the yeah that's what the
correspondence center is like and you're
like but you're supposed to be
against each other guys that's when you
realize when we went to dc that's when i
was wrestling
huh um when we went to dc that's when i
realized
this is they're all playing you all
they're
all friends they all know each other
they're not friends but
they know each other they don't hate
each other they hate each other for you
because you think pelosi is a bad person
but all those people know each other
yeah all those people
say hi to each other's wives and
husbands i remember hearing
jake tapper say that he knew
um what's the little worm who works for
trump
the bald one uh so many bald ones so
many worms the [ __ ]
the main worm who writes all this [ __ ]
but like he knew steve bannon but
basically like right yeah like i know
them socially i know i have his number
yes they all don't know don't have his
number
they all you have to have each other
everyone knows each other yeah
everyone is like it's just like a
crowded room
full of like a bunch of people who are
social
tolerance priorities take
precedence over scruples
scruples scruples scruples uh
did you think though because we were
very critical of the dnc so did you
think there was a more effective
no i think they made the same mistake
to me i'm like i watched it i thought of
what you were saying
they talked about so much about race
they tried to make it that like he's not
racist
yeah for so long and by the way like you
did you see they all like rand paul got
harassed out on the way home so funny
that's great
uh he was like but the question is and
it
the this is what i wanted to talk about
with all this stuff is
do they is that going to affect the
election
is seeing white
whether it's port like the the cities on
fire
because to me it's not true i don't
think anyone's
actually afraid of their city being in
trouble i was talking to somebody who
lived like right off fairfax
here and was like yes it's like a war
zone but for six hours
yeah it's not like we're on the joe
biden's america
is she's gonna your mom's as good as
raped
if you vote for joe biden so
that's the so does rand paul getting
heckled on the street
scare moderate white people into
voting for republicans i could see how
it would
optically look a little bit scarier but
i
i think we're as a nation getting
really numb to a lot of [ __ ] well yes
the
whole thing that trump
doing the speech on the white house at
the white house lawn
is trump did the thing
where you know when there's like uh in a
movie like what are you gonna do shoot
all of us
it's like yeah trump basically did the
thing of like what are you gonna do
prosecute me for everything
everything i do is illegal that's all
i'm exactly i
it's the only time i've seen the police
like quit
the the regulations he ward
out regulations he stared down
regulation
was like no not doing that one not doing
that one not doing that one
to the point where regulations like with
we're not needed here
we should just get out of here there's
no somehow
the rules just don't apply to him um but
that's watching it i just thought
i wonder if that is gonna
i don't think it will mar bill maher
said he thinks it will
i kind of don't the other thing that is
that did you see the black lives matter
people
forcing the white surrounding the white
woman to like put her to put her fist up
that was so funny
right but it's you see you know it's
crazy
absolutely backward it is and how
absolutely
power corrupts absolute power corrupts
absolutely
they just we don't like getting bullied
until it's our chance to bully
and then we're gonna make you raise your
fist meanwhile the lady had been
marching with them
listen i go to these marches they don't
always go well
and this is just amongst uh what do you
mean by they don't go well
well it's a bunch of charged people who
are very passionate and
um there's no real leader you know there
is a leader of like each march and stuff
but
it is not this kind of like it's not
like we're watching the march we're part
of it
so the participation everybody can
participate so you can start a chant you
can sort of this you can
and you're with a bunch of people you
don't [ __ ] know yeah we're only
really linked by
one or a few commonalities so sometimes
some people will
start a weird chance or like
this so i was at the one in oakland that
was at the port author
the port and it was done by
the oakland port authority who were like
the black
like oakland dudes that work for the
port authority and they were
they started this march so when it ended
they were like everybody could come up
everybody to write their name and come
up and speak
and there was a late there was like a
woman i think
i don't know i couldn't tell who was
shouting and they're like
yo man don't don't shout just write your
name
and he was like i'm not a [ __ ] man
did you just assume
my gender and it's like brother brother
it's like
everyone's like what are you doing and
it's like
um sorry and then they were like so much
infighting and
we remind you on the same side so then
they finally got let them go on stage
and they're like we're just saying stop
shouting out
okay and it's like brother you need to
and everyone's like did you just call me
brother
he's like i'm sorry he's this old black
man he's like
i'm sorry for calling this
sister a brother and i'm like in my head
i'm like this guy's head's exploding
yeah
he's like an old guy but that's what
that's what they're what they do
moderate white people
that's the logic that they want moderate
white people to accept i ever tell you
i was on at largo
and there was a trans comedian on stage
a uh from woman to man
and i was on the side of the stage with
a female comic
i won't say but she's great and
hilarious and
like a kind person and she goes we're
watching the
guy do stand up and she goes like what
do his
genitals look like oh okay and i go
i go i i don't know
and i said and we're the liberals
right we're the as kind of as
woke as you can be so imagine what our
parents think
our parents are like what in the [ __ ]
like it's terrifying
right and the thing that liberals don't
do
is accept
increments there's only one measurement
yeah you got to be on the right
all or nothing now you're on the wrong
side now yeah
you want to get on the right side then
[ __ ] you the problem is let's say for
that example in oakland
it is i feel like like like on the trans
woman's side
yo i'm marching with you and we're
really monitoring for like black lives
matter but
when it comes to trans people there is
this huge issue and so i felt like
they they just felt unheard and although
i didn't think that was the right way to
go about it the whole thing just ended
up being
really unorganized and it was just hard
to stand there being like yay
marching and being like uh so i'm
calling a brother man yeah like getting
a beer about that it just gets hijacked
by another liberal issue
but that no one will no the other thing
about
liberals is no liberal will ever say
not right now for my thing there's no
prior
everything is number one so if you're
trans if you're
whatever the multiplicity of issues
there are
on the liberal side they all are number
one
so if at that point
we're dealing with black lives matter oh
no but there is there's hypocrisy
because there's a lot of homophobia in
the black community community and a lot
of people just don't understand trans
a lot of people are like but even i just
said i said the female comics said
what does generals look like and you
exhaled like it was troublesome
but meanwhile how do we we can't
ask i just don't think like there's
plenty
you know i know your needs i'm just
asking
plenty of [ __ ] look different so why
do you need to know what mine is my do i
have meat curtains
they look different once and then
they're gone
but they deviate from the way i like
them i'm just saying do you need to know
labia and get out of my it's not like
when i see you and will get out of my
limo
it's not like when i see you you and
will i'm like ooh what are their like
pink dicks are they smaller what if all
we did was talk
[Music]
what if all we did was talk about
our if our entire act and and
identity was based on what we did to our
genitals
i still can't ask i would expect you
would have some questions
yeah but and then what importance are we
putting on your
understanding of an intimate thing of
mine just who cares just like oh
whatever
it's like where you go hey do uh
paraplegics
have sex and then they go yeah i can get
a boner or whatever it's like
ask me anything and they go yeah and
you're like oh [ __ ] i didn't know that
but the world is very nice
for the most part very nice to people
who are uh
you know handy physically handicapped
for like you know
we have ramps everyone's no one's like
[ __ ] that crippled guy
they're they're not very nice of trans
people so it ends up being a bit more
like
what's going on no but again that's what
you ascribe to this woman saying what do
his genitals look like
she wasn't loading a gun like what to
hey before i shoot this
but you [ __ ] no no you know as
well as i do that
it's the it's the energy around it's
like the times right now we're still at
a time where that is confusing
you know it's not like trans people are
being supported but that's the problem
is
that is confusing and you can't ask i'm
not saying you can't ask but i'm just
saying
she asked quietly to me thinking i might
know that's what i'm saying like
i think you can ask your friend but also
are you going to walk up to a black
person and be like
a black woman be like your [ __ ] lips
purple i heard they were purple like no
you're not going to ask like what is it
like no but that's a if her
entire identity
and most of the things she spoke about
was based around a thing she had done to
her vagina i would have questions about
it but it isn't only about a thing that
she had
this person had done to their vagina or
penis it's about their
personality it's like i'm a gender that
goes with
that but you know what i mean it's silly
that you're not allowed to ask
about i'm not saying you're not allowed
to ask but let's say when white people
want to ask black people questions that
they feel a little uncomfortable they
generally either one write to
our show or
they don't exactly know how to navigate
even if they want to know you know and
there is this kind of like
don't ask that or you shouldn't ask that
but i don't agree with we by the way
we did a segment entrepreneurship called
ask a black dude and ask it like we
knew that there was a there's something
to this
for and there is an element of
for any group it's just the description
of
bad faith like why are you
do you have something no i i have
genitals
i know what one kind of genital looks
like generally and i know what another
kind looks like generally
and i'm wondering what it looks like
when you go from this to that
the thing is though what i'm saying is
that you too
not like being close with that trans
woman
i think if you were if i didn't know you
two and you came up and asked me a
question about my blackness or what's my
hair like
that's weird but if you knew if you knew
if you had a friend that was a trans
woman i think you can ask them and i
think if we
if we uh if we asked a bunch of trans
people
i'm sure they get asked a lot of
questions i don't think people aren't
what i'm saying is
i talked about me and somebody backstage
and they're asking me that
and you exhale like there was uh be
on some be careful [ __ ] not like i was
gonna get in trouble but like there's
something wrong with that
and what i'm saying is that's the thing
that liberals don't do
is admit that there is a thing
whether it's mysterious or new or it's
like when
breast implants started people were like
what does it feel like
no i'm my my exhale came from if you
don't know the person like
she didn't know i know we didn't ask no
i understand my and that's
the worry is if you can't ask
i think it makes the person
[Music]
uh superior do you know what i mean
it makes sense it makes me less apt to
uh makes them weirdly like
not less human but just a different
we're talking about someone
genitals you so do you mean the
center of our existence yeah it's a huge
thing
i understand but what what we're talking
about actually is having a conversation
being like what does that person's
genitals look like if you don't know
that person
i do think there's not like you're not
entitled to ask everybody what you want
that was where mine i know but i'm not
i'm not saying
we we're rushing the state there's no
ill intent other than
like i wonder what it looks like like
but you're fighting against like why
can't i ask
no one's thinking no no you just said
like no no no what i said was
she said that to me and i go i don't
know and we're
super woke liberals imagine what our
parents think
and those the parents are the ones that
need the
questions that no no that that liberals
need to pick off to vote for
biden and which is the thing that i sent
you the aoc
aoc basically reiterated what i'd said
which is
she had a different sort of take on it
which is she didn't think there was
the she said that the reason there
wasn't more representation
on the uh on the
on the lineup at the convention was
because they were trying to pick off
moderate whites
and it's like well you [ __ ] didn't do
that enough
like that you didn't you didn't pick
them off like you were it was still
all race gender but so was
the rnc rnz was back yes because they're
afraid of it yeah and they're not gonna
they're using it
as a fear thing and
liberals are using it as a it's right
it's only right don't you want to be
good yeah
don't you want to be and it's like they
don't they might not care
they mean the republicans i'm not
convinced
trump's not going to win do you know
what i mean like oh no i'm not super
confident about it but i just have a
feeling that like
there are a lot of people who are still
flying them trunk flags
like that's i don't think he's going and
they all have boats
okay the weirdest thing oh that's never
like boat people i've been telling
you i never like the culture i don't
like i don't like
water i don't like boats i don't like
docks it's so funny that you say that so
that's another thing i did
men's bare feet you know like men's
bodies
um the another thing i did this week
was i went paddle boarding in the oc
and let me tell you we're lucky that
you're alive that you're still here i
made it out alive
and uh great social distance cool
whatever the amount and this is like
there's a lot of waterfront properties
along where you paddleboard
paddleboard it was like
trump trump biden trump these are all
neighbors trump trump trump trump
fighting by inviting trump
trump fighting bodybuilding it was just
like a matrix just like one zero zero
one
who who was winning uh trump yeah but
i also am not surprised if you
vote trump in your these are 10 million
homes
so of course you're [ __ ] for trump
yeah like i said that
racism and money are a winning
combination
right but for a lot for most of american
history if
trump wasn't racist but was still for
rich people
i think people i don't think they could
be that they want all
i said this last week liberals say
hey don't you want to do what's right
and
republicans say hey you want [ __ ]
money
and a lot of times they'll they'll dress
it up
as some other [ __ ] yeah like a real
american compassionate conservatism or
or compassionate conservatism or um
uh reagan was all sort of stars and
stripes and
bush was sort of somewhere in the middle
but um
george h walker uh but
but trump is just like
dog you want [ __ ] money you trying to
get this paper
and that's why like it's eight thirteen
percent with black people that in a poll
on trump i'm like yeah unemployment was
low
they people are simple and they don't
realize
it was just a trajectory that was on its
way down but
now the economy is cyclical it's like
trump
people think it's like guys yeah i don't
especially credit obama or clinton or i
mean
i do a bit more nafta i mean how i don't
it's it's
it's just when he got in there it's when
he got in there but i do think some of
his
tax policies did help get out of a
deficit i mean because we weren't in a
deficit
yes that well that's a separate issue
it's
the economy it's it's so like bush that
was cyclical but it really looked bad
because it was like great economy and
then boom as soon as you take it well
that
you could make a case was political in
that it's all deregulation and
that's because republicans hate
government and they go like government
doesn't work
we'll show you let's put us in charge
and we'll prove it to you right
exactly um so
like the the
i still think that
i'm not convinced that racism and money
isn't a good combo
oh no i think you're right and and so
that's why i was saying
if you're that's why liberals should
have talked about
uh coveted and
jobs and judges
that's the thing that i was like you
were like what should they talk about
they [ __ ] mentioned
i don't think they should mention judges
why not
because the people they're going to pick
off are conservative
yeah you may be right and but that's the
you may be right but i think
biden is in turn
is is kind of conservative
in terms of he has conservative enough
energy that it's like
like right now there's more bigger fish
to fry
than who's gonna be the [ __ ] judge
and that's yes so what i would say to
your point which is all right take
judges off
just don't focus on [ __ ] race and
gender
it's you're my mom doesn't care the nice
thing she had her chance
she's 87 turns out if you're
born in 1933 in the south side of
chicago
it's not a huge [ __ ] issue it's never
gonna be
never gonna be she my mom said she
remembered like a school being racist
when she was a little girl and just
being like
huh right like that seems anti-christian
but she didn't march
it's like that when people know that
there are animals in really bad
conditions
and it feels bad and it's like [ __ ] that
makes you feel really bad for eating
meat
and then you go and you just is there
already chicken wings is dinner go get
bees what is that
what's that smell what's it like that
animal it doesn't affect you it's not
in your it's not in your world so you're
like well
so like it'd be like running on race and
gender
for the liberals would be like animals
like i don't
really care i don't care is it wrong yes
it's wrong
it but if you're trying to get people in
the middle
they don't [ __ ] care about that i
will say
i think people are [ __ ] burning
out on this [ __ ] so i don't think it was
that i think especially
women but what i'm saying is there's a
way to do it
where it's not even so much as like
we're gonna
the women are gonna because i don't
believe that women think that a woman's
gonna save the day because they
especially white women because they
voted against hillary so i don't think
that
the gender of the person is dictates
an outcome for women no i mean that like
i don't know how impactful the dnc and
the rnc were
because we're so i don't think they had
any impact
i don't think i just i you know what the
thing is i think if they were held
before [ __ ] started opening and before
the
the protesting and stuff and george
floyd
i actually think everybody would have
watched because we were so we had this
weird like
you know desert of not getting anything
but there's
multiple articles that say they don't
make a difference i'm sure they don't
but i'm just saying
any conditions 2016 didn't make it they
just don't make no i just mean before
that we really were
at a we were in you know how there's
food deserts we were in like
yes but we're like in a news desert it's
a very small window
yeah it was like a you 10 days but this
is
a weird year whereas like if something
was here or if covet hit
now like i don't know it just this is
like strange weirdest yeah
like weirdest year i've ever been a lot
obviously
but it's like there's some movies that
came out
right when lockdown happened that would
have never gone to number one
yeah that you know i just mean like
there are these it's just funny how
things are
we still are so far away from the
election i feel like so much shit's
gonna happen i know
um so oh well we've gotta rest and
we've got a rest in power king a
legitimate rest in power king
yeah russ and power king to chadwick
boseman
43 um
which would have mean i would have been
i would have died
three years ago that's when i think
about that's the thing the older you get
you just think about all the [ __ ] you've
done
since that age yeah you're like [ __ ]
it's like
[ __ ] yeah you think about yourself you
think about
how long i mean that's it's obvious but
the older you get the more you
understand
time and the value of it um
and uh and so
uh the thing that i thought we could
talk about
is if you
how would you be about sharing a health
thing
in public that's the thing i
actually think he went about it
in a really admirable way but i think a
lot of people would
i don't know i i'm really private so i
don't think i would
but i'm surprised i think most people
would have said something
yeah i don't i don't i don't know i
truly don't know
what most people you know a lot of
celebrities do you think a lot of them
would highly i think a lot of them have
colon cancer
um no i think uh do people hide a lot of
i mean i'm sure they do well you
what if someone doesn't want to hire you
because you're you have cancer that's
that that's the it's in some ways it's
like
homosexuality like
it like it kills the face that doesn't
help it doesn't help
when i don't want to watch black panther
and go it's [ __ ]
cancer i was like he's gonna die soon
yeah that's the whole
you just think about it the whole time
whether you
occasionally you wouldn't but if
i knew he had uh it was prostate or
colon
i think it was colin yeah um if i knew
the whole time
i would have been distracted so it's
it's like when patrick swayze
he was on this series while he was doing
cancer treatment
and that's all you can think about yeah
especially because they had this one
scene and it was
it was like a interrogation scene and
there was one like falling out
okay literally it wasn't even in the
script no one talked about it he kept
combing his hair clumps go ahead
wow no one's off the limits guys no it's
really dedicated
come on two cents you know he
like i just you could see how yeah gaunt
and
he just like it was distracting like you
said and it made me
really sad this podcast because i look
like i have something wrong with me
when it comes to announcements you're
fat
again you're fat i'm in good shape uh
so that i think he did
the right thing yeah i had a discussion
one time
with a gay celebrity about how they
believed that
more actors should come out and i was
like
okay yeah and i was like no [ __ ] no
bad idea tom cruise doesn't i don't want
to see his movies more
if he comes out well it's like the
people that there are rumors about
hugh jackman it's never going to benefit
just going like
you know what guys or whomever whoever
else i'm outing
um whoever i don't know who else i'm
outing
um uh sean hey i'm kidding
um well no i know he's sean
i mean i think he's out yeah because he
did the
i remember he did the three stooges
movie and
uh a guy was trying to bring up yeah oh
yeah i don't think he talks about it
but he's right to not talk about it yeah
you know like of course why would you
what's the guy that came out he was
spock
uh zach quinto yeah it just
doesn't help i don't if i'm
watching a scene where he's trying to
make out with a girl i'm like
you don't even like girls the thing is
it's so
unfair we want to know everything about
a celebrity
on tv let's say we want to know
everything but
we don't and then it's like ooh you're
better off
not much not knowing anything
honestly you're better off i think the
people that do it right
frank ocean total total
mystery but that's a musician's a little
different because you can still make
i don't care if i like the song i like
the song yeah whereas when it's tv or
film
it's like if you watched a play in the
playbill it was like gay
yeah like why who gives a [ __ ] well i'm
also assuming a lot of these guys are
gay when i'm watching like a broadway
play hello
but it doesn't take away anything so
it's just funny how we
get so like worked up when it's a tv
actor it's like
you watch plays well and it just doesn't
help
to know but i don't get the psychology
of why
if someone's gay cancer i get more gay
like
gives a [ __ ] it's fake you idiots
they're not real
but they don't they don't believe that
they don't believe that they don't it's
real it's true i watch the good doctor
which everyone makes fun of me about
and i'm like is he really autistic maybe
he's a little
the kid who plays he plays the same guy
plays like norman bates
oh god i got it he goes he goes he's uh
the show is about him being autistic
at an autistic doctor the show is every
weeks he get he gets a vaccine
and then the second half of the show
he's autistic i'm an anti-vaccine guys
and i want you to know
uh no but so rest in power kang yes um
you he seemed like a nice dude
and it's truly sad it's really
funny that like hurt it was like i
literally thought like
man [ __ ] god better [ __ ] take it
easy on black like
black people are going to swing on god
if god
sight
anything i'm stevie wonder or beyonce
it's on site um
[Music]
okay adele
who i now refer to as adelezol after
rachel dolezal
that's some adele's all [ __ ] right there
she really looks she has dolezal eyes
in this she's adele alone she could do
that i like it
but that's the thing is because
you like her music you're like ah that's
not it
i just don't think i think
that she's clicked into the black
culture in uk is different
and we want to go talk about it like
from our vantage point but
black culture in the uk is way more like
caribbean african influences that are
more prevalent
you know and it's and so she's so
clicked in that i'm like
i'm gonna screw face you keep okay screw
face chopped and screwed face
and i just think
we can't all we i feel like if
people in if black people in the uk
don't understand
why i've seen stop i've seen some
conversations or they're like
i don't understand chicken watermelon
like i don't get the references or i
don't get these
personal cultural references here and i
get it
i get why you don't get it you know it's
a weird thing
i just feel like not we can't always
comment
just because it's a black thing like i
don't [ __ ] know what she does for the
black community
appropriations appropriation no that's
true and i
i i saw those knots i was like damn
adult
folded on that well no i agree with you
yeah i don't think i'm like
this is this this is the word neil of
god like
the the braids yeah like the feathers
the plumage no the feathers it's just
like carnival haven't you been or will
you
no i'm with you but white i don't think
that white british people
dress like that because of caribbean
culture i don't think that
that's accepted white she does
i'm saying black british people
obviously do black people with caribbean
roots
obviously do or if you're black if
you're african you want to dress like
that [ __ ] knock yourself out and that
is my edict
um but her i don't know
i don't i don't think that there's i
don't think that our lack of
understanding british culture is
can prevent us from going like that's a
foul
no i think we can i think we can
i don't think we should be the authority
on if it's a foul that's all i don't
uh i don't think that we're an authority
but i always thought
uh i know the record canceled her and
i'm not she's not no
no i don't give a [ __ ] it's a foul i
think that's fine i don't think it's a
flagrant
two i don't think she's getting ejected
i think
caribbean people are shooting a
technical and they get the ball but what
if caribbean people
in the uk are like she fine
leave her be bomba glad
i think first of all there's what how
what amount of caribbean people can
exonerate that's the thing is
you're making it weird
it's a foul well that's what i'm saying
if the caribbean people who
which ones okay if something happened
here and black people are
uh if outraged and [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh if uh uh
it's what's his name spec spectrum
what's the kid's name the the rapper who
skeptical yeah spectrum okay
so if somebody appropriated something
i mean it's not a good example because
like she's just going to get dragged
no it's we just it's a foul straight up
raise your hand adele you made a you
foul
flagrant it's a flagrant one shout out
to uh
[ __ ] andrew schultz flag the flagrant
tupac it's a flagrant one
you're not kicked out but one more and
you're getting a flag and two and you
gotta go
i don't know what that means either but
the braids are kind of that's the only
thing i'm like
god did you need to do the bantu know
she it's straight up
cultural appropriation just straight up
opening shut up
i'm an amazing artist adele
a [ __ ] great singer right from what i
understand a decent lady
flag a little too familiar yeah i'm it's
a flagrant one
for me i'm not any sort of but i'm just
saying
on this podcast the flaker ones okay um
and you i've been calling adele adelezol
um well let's do some emails
l s t n h
[Music]
l s t
[Music]
[Applause]
that's nice what's up neil and banks lst
ner i really appreciate how you guys
discuss mental health especially bipolar
disorder because
it gets left out of the conversation a
lot of the time my heart goes out to
people living with severe bipolar who
have super dramatic highs and lows
but there are also tons of us who have
milder forms
and just need the right combination of
meds to live a normal healthy life
i'm in my 30s i was diagnosed bipolar
when i was 18
and thanks to therapy and medication my
mood is as stable as the average person
i'm not stuck in catatonia and most
people wouldn't guess on bipolar as long
as they don't look in my medicine
cabinet
a real mood booster for me was when neil
sent me a topless photo for calling him
a saloon hooker on instagram
i also gained a lot of clout at work
when i showed everybody that i got a
nude pick from a celebrity so
thanks again neil i love you guys i mean
it's a topless
are you sending news yeah i'm saying
yeah i wanted her to see my dick
i wanted her bipolar eyes to see my my
depressive addict dick um
uh yeah i was
reminded of something um our
the philosopher dave croppell said once
which was everything's funny until it
happens to you
yeah so everyone's like everything and
then ah
no it's off limits i'm like no so i
don't even
when she said bipolar gets left out of
the conversation
i think people don't like talking about
mental health
period i think it all gets left out of
the conversation and
um i think that's one of them
people don't like people aren't dying to
talk about depression no no
or or borderline or any of them
so i'm happy to talk about it because i
don't think it's a big deal but
you know if i can help one bipolar
person at that apparently what i heard
she left it she will cut it out but
apparently
when she saw my topless she had a manic
episode
ended up in the street like martin
luther king
she had a manic episode and was out of
her mind she thought the fbi is after
her
and she uh she shot
she punched a lot of um windows out in
stores
and that happens for some women when
they see a
real a powerful nude but yeah by the way
it was mostly
women who wanted it
why was it for guys when you don't even
like looking at guys because
i because they're the ones who go
[ __ ]
aids or math or does neil all right i'm
seriously
wondering just post it neil no
oh my god why would i because then i bet
i'm dalia
and kamehameha i don't want to be a
topless you don't have to flex like
camille
that was weird but i don't think any
comedian
should ever post a it's
i'm liv i'm walking the walk because
this is why i didn't want aoc
doing makeup videos it's not what i'm
that's not what you don't mind if i dmd
then she privately sent me a makeup
a zillion times please i dare you
okay what were you gonna say about nudes
i don't remember it was so recently i
this is staggering it was like seven
minutes ago
that's staggering you forget [ __ ] all
the time i i
i yeah what i'm gonna cancel this
podcast
and wait what do you mean what was i you
just said i'll bring it up
when we talk about it oh oh yeah
so so you know i made a joke of like
yeah and tell me i like
it and then that you were gonna send all
of a sudden like i
after the after the audio dropped i got
all these
really insulting dms and i was so
offended oh why people joking like you
don't
you're ugly yeah gross and i was like
that's so before you realized what they
were doing but it was so many i was like
this is weird something's off
the rand ranford's curve
um and so i and then
and i blocked youtube then i had to go
remember their names and unblock them
it's so funny
so i don't think i've ever someone
requested an unblock
once and i like went through and was
like all right you know but i
mostly no i just felt stupid obviously
it was what i asked them to do and they
blocked them
and they're probably like hey i thought
we were having fun
no it's not a game bro no don't tell me
i'm ugly i don't like your tone don't
you [ __ ] tell me that goodbye
you've got mail hey neil and bianca love
the pot and all the rest
anyways not out of any real sense of
moral indignation or anything but i
thought i'd take a crack
at this megan the stallion joke
controversy no
so if it's okay to make fun of people
getting shot it should be okay to make
fun of people getting robbed
but you had nothing on ellen did you get
robbed
yeah that's why i didn't it's like what
do you mean i did yeah she got robbed
[ __ ] people get robbed all the time
if you say there's no jokes there here's
two
okay this guy wanted it his name is
delivery
good mike i i can't do there's no way to
deliver these jokes well they're saying
because they don't even make so this guy
wanted us to read jokes on the air
and his name is mike from minnesota okay
mike
here it goes this is your dream come
true
the ears are the jokes that mike from
minnesota had on allen
uh if there's okay
quote the joke is starting now
there's got to be an easier way to get
androgynous pull over sweaters
what that and then robbing
oh okay and
um this one is this one
is so bad i'm afraid they're gonna take
us out
of apple podcast i'm afraid that they're
gonna cancel
i'm afraid youtube's gonna have to close
can i read this one yes
okay joke's starting now no it's a joke
isn't that a carjacking cause porsha
sounds like porsche
that is so painfully and funny god isn't
that a carjacking because
porsche sounds like porsche dude
terrible
bad stop this is i told you the thing
[ __ ] seinfeld
when simon was on everyone would go like
you guys i wrote a spec you should
and they were gonna i heard the joke
that
from a writer that they were just gonna
take someone's spec
and film it without any rewrites just to
show someone like
we're not even in the same category
right
shush it mike from minnesota
[ __ ] shush
how about that mike from minnesota
honestly i like to quote
uh to paraphrase billy madison
uh we're all less funny
for having heard those jokes
that's jim downey said that in the snl
writers room and then they
reappropriated it in billy madison in
the quiz
worship yeah that's based on somebody
pitched something in down he said we're
all less funny for having heard that
it's one of the greatest burns of all
time um
jim downey one of the hall of fame
sketchers anyhow
next letter goodbye mike don't ever
write again
mike mike you're you're you're on
punishment mike i don't know what that
means
but you're on punishment that's a
flagrant two for un
funny you've got mayo hi neil and bianca
and will
rstn lar i've been listening since week
one
and seriously look forward to the new
episodes every tuesday i'm genuinely
grateful for your insights and the
laughs you provide for
so many of us listeners well that's nice
especially while living alone and
coordinating just wanted to share a
personal anecdote
i'm a cookbook author and two weeks ago
my newest the one pot casserole cookbook
came out despite my publisher and
marketing team adamantly discouraging it
leading up to and since the book's
release i've been referring to myself as
the one pot thought every chance i get
that almost feels like mike could have
written it mike from minnesota yeah
it's not that bad it's better than mike
it's better than mike for sure
so i all this to say get me my pots
we'll start the song now and the
accompanying songs have completely
rocked my world
a long term feeler dream come true and
that's nice
thank you i'll bake and ship you guys
vegan cookies any day
oh sarah i actually want to see
i want okay keep going
i i actually use my instapot a lot
and i want i might buy her cookbook
you're well you're sounds like you're a
one-pot thought that's gonna be a
one-pot
instant thought you got it that's good
you got a thotty mouth over
um p.s when when anil said guys want
sex and girls want attention and
relationships shouldn't be
work they should be about maintaining
like a pool
god damn i've thought about those
statements almost every day since
could not agree more and those who think
neither are true
lee and denial goodbye you've got mail
hi neil and bianca
i just wanted to add to bianca's point
about european
intellectual defensive racism i've come
i've just come to sweden for work and
the conversations about race are
super stupid hey we'll bring this up
because she has pictures
uh the other day i was at work i was at
a work event telling a group of poc
how white swedes are so white they
started checking in on me a mongolian
swede
during the george floyd protest they
didn't believe me
but then a white guy joins our table and
asked me
if i'm amy say a gambian swedish woman
this is a little too specific right and
then this man has worked at the same
place as her for years
now in his defense in different
departments again
a little too specific while everyone
else starts dispersing to discreetly
laugh at him i stay and politely answer
questions about genghis khan
katanas kimchi and other random asian
things he's into
for another two to three minutes because
i'm super non-confrontational
but i hope to be as overt as bianca is
one day
hear that she hopes to be as overweight
as you are one day love the podcast
now you see the two women and uh
the she's a this woman is a
she's a mongolian swede and
um and uh somebody else
is a gambian swede so the dum-dum
that sat and asked her questions about
genghis khan and kimchi
you know neil is the same thing you
wanted
to ask the trans woman
yes i think you should be able to ask i
mean again i wouldn't
i know you wouldn't if somebody's
converted
if somebody's entire act was about
i used to be white now i'm asian
i would have some questions about
asian-ness
especially if the entire culture was
built around it now which one of those
women
i don't know who's who but they're
that's right the top one's gambian the
bottom one's mongolian of course
but you know who's who no no i don't
know who's who in terms of
the top one's amy say um amy say
is the tough one uh no
they didn't that's what i'm saying it's
confusing they didn't believe me but
then a white guy joins our table and
asks if
i'm abe amy say a gambian swedish woman
yeah that's
her the black woman the black woman is
amy say
right and the bottom woman is the right
say
say amy what do you mean i'm wrong i'm
telling
i'm right now but i but i don't
understand but the woman on the bottom
is the one who stayed around for the
question the woman at the bottom
is the woman the whole time someone came
sat next to her and said are you amy say
a totally different woman that wasn't at
the table and it's like no i'm not amy
say i'm
mongolian swedish i'm say amy
but then she stick around to answer
questions
about kimchi the lady on the bottom dude
yeah
but why did he have why was he asking
him a
gambian woman about kimchi we didn't say
are you the gambian swedish woman name
you say he just said are you let me say
like are you the girl
my point is this guy might beats like
autisticism because for
wow to look at the woman on top and go
on i'm gonna ask her about
kimchi and katanas don't disparage the
good doctor unless she's like the
the swedish version of ghost dog
the the uh i love ghosts that's why i
put it out there
she's the swedish ghost dog in whatever
company this is
and she there's no reason to ask that
woman
about the ghost dog about kimchi katanas
or other random asians goodbye you've
got mail hi neil and cianka
hi felin thianka hi love the podcast
after there are
nick cannon's anti-semitic remarks i
spent some time going down internet
rabbit holes on louis farrakhan
while i respect farrakhan's unshakable
comment to black people
commitment he definitely seems to hold
some very anti-semitic views
definitely i think that's unquestionable
my question is this how do you feel
about j
electronica and by association jay-z
j electronica reps nation of islam hard
and says some anti-semitic things
on a written testimony e.g for example
quote satan struck palestine with yet
another mortar
um that doesn't seem that anti-semitic
but whatever
jay elect is an extremely talented
rapper and the album received great
reviews and it is some
definite uh anti-semitic overtones
uh i enjoy the album but upon learning
more about farrakhan and the nation of
islam i feel
more and more guilty for having listened
for listening to it uh
can noxious views ruin the aesthetic
achievement of an album
in spite of his talent should jay elect
be cancelled and what responsibility
does jc have
given that he appears on eight of the
ten tracks uh is he guilty part of
participating in
and therefore tacitly condoning the
creation of anti-semitic work of art
and did music critics generally get it
wrong by seemingly giving elections
for anti-semitic views in light of the
historical and ongoing impression of
black people
curious here what do you think okay i
the
i thank you for listening but some of
you should some of this is super
annoying to read
like the like should jay-z i know you're
just posing the question but
this sort of shits the problem ah here's
what i want to say to
letters like this dog you know you could
have written this to a congress person
no but like did the what is it the the
music critics
seemingly give him a path like this is
so it's all
like cultural criticism like and what
part does
why would you want to emulate a person
who talks like this
and one must also hold up
you long to read things in an
in a academic esoteric way like that's
your
that's like i can't wait to talk about
[ __ ] like that it's [ __ ]
i don't want to [ __ ] on them i just
think they're they're giving us
hey these are things maybe we can
discuss but
there there's there's a lot of i'm so so
tired of
this i can't even i'm i like reached a
new plateau with the meg of the stallion
ship where it's just like
dude enough with like
it's so dumb that
all you here's that my final megan
selling point
would i have made fun of any black woman
getting shot in the foot
not in a million years because there's
nothing funny about it
if you're named after a horse i'm going
to do a hoof joke i'm going to do a
uh animal hospital joke i'm going to do
those jokes
case closed you're still mad about it
and you always
mad i'm just i'm tired i'm just i'm um
if you watch back the reading of it last
week you're like don't
yeah because it's glaring at me no that
that's your interpretation
i i mean literally i'm just sitting
there trying to really
one i was i love how glaring is
sometimes you're the woman you don't
want to date i'm like listening to you
and
i hope so i'm listening to you intently
she was glaring at me obviously
no one's listening listening i listen i
did something wrong no i literally
listened to you
and trying to fully [ __ ] i'm kidding uh
no i listened and i
well do you want to talk about a [ __ ]
under perfect length
underused go ahead okay
just don't play it again at all um
no i i that that the only thing i looked
i just was like i felt like we talked
about it but i
felt you hit something hit you in a more
personal
way with that guy's letter and so you
didn't let it go
more it's just so like why would you
want
to it's the moral version of pocket
watching
meaning like how much money it's like
the the
shakedown yeah it's like what do you why
are you doing
guy the guy who just wrote this jay
electronica record
throw away your [ __ ] dr dre it ain't
no fun if the homies can't have none
is one of the grossest songs ever
committed to
analog tape and then of course
transferred to digital
um i mean there's so many awful notions
in almost all music so
i just feel like yo we could do this
what he did
on everybody we can do it on there's
plenty of jewish people we could do it
on there's plenty of
christians we can do on we can run right
left black white
i was listening yeah seth rogen said
last week that they that
he was lied to as a as a jew about
israel and they never told them that
palestinians were already living yes so
are we canceling superb
and then he got he received backlash
from jewish community not a lot i don't
think but
this guy is like should we go back i
just think it's
it's like dude no one's living some
squeaky clean
anything so i don't know i don't know
i mean do you you want to go down the
road fine but everybody i don't want to
go down there what i'm saying is yes
what i'm saying is like
dawg you got it this guy's got a decent
brain
you're throwing it away on you're
throwing it away you don't know what
he's doing on
he's i he's throwing it away this kid
this kid could do something of value and
he's like
i was listening to a j electronic
i was this is a separate notion but
if you told me j electronica never
released that album
it doesn't that's how little impact you
can have
i was like j electronica's album
someone's giving like
what are we talking about the window
used to be 72 hours of relevance
yeah and now it's down to like eight
somebody pointed out like billy eilish
released a song last week and people
were like
amazing and then put it on tick-tock i
don't [ __ ] know
great gone if it doesn't have a dance it
doesn't stick around yeah
it's it's basically skeets cultural ski
shooting
whereas like billy has and then [ __ ]
beyonce's remix would make this sound
and then here comes [ __ ] fiona apple
i remember when fiona apple's record
came out i don't know eight weeks ago
a woman wrote i wonder if men are gonna
be okay after this fiona apple record
and i wanted to write to be like
lady you're so out of you're so far up
your own ass
you understand that albums by
40 year old women don't really have the
impact they used to
they too to you because she's your age
but if you're not
a 25 year old like j electronic 40 year
old rapper
what the funny thing is when you made
the like the
dr dre comparison um i was listening to
that that next song
too close and it's like i wonder if you
could tell them hard right now
and then there's another there's all
this i was like this is the worst it's
illegal
literally like like girl lap dancing
every
i know you're making it hard for me
she's like i can feel a
bump coming through on you i'm like this
is
sexual harassment and assault right like
now
but at the time we were all dancing it
was fun
yeah yeah [ __ ] great dick this guy
had his ear to the speaker
i wonder if maybe we shouldn't take a
look
at whoever the [ __ ] is in next because i
don't know
who the [ __ ] is in next was cisco in
next
no he's just joe hill dude you know what
this is we're going to tell him now
cisco now was spectrum
was spectrum next we just need to
re-fucking relax
let it go yeah enjoy the music bro
because you're not
it's also don't think about your phone
because it was not
or your sneakers or most of your clothes
or
your pots and pans or your car or
it's all nothing everything is morally
dubious
at best at bet the best you can hope for
is like
right the bet that's peak peak
peak peak
here this is all you thanks well there's
a song oh of course
there's a song that i play the horny one
quiet it down trade it down bianca
two two one q bianca's reading
hey neil and bianca i love oral pleasure
giving and receiving my boyfriend loves
receiving
and refuses to give we've been together
two years
and he's never done it we've talked
about it
about what we enjoy sexually and i've
made it very clear to him going down on
me as expected
just as much as me going down on him i
feel deprived
from a lady in a gents perspective how
do you feel about
giving and receiving oral sex in a
relationship
and would it be a deal breaker if
what a lonely [ __ ] huh what a lonely
ass position bone dry
bone drug [ __ ] fast a bone dry
also every guy i've ever dated that was
a little
squirmish uh-huh they always came around
wow i always came around um
also um well i guess technically sexual
assault
just like i don't know just when they're
sleeping put your [ __ ] on their face
[ __ ] wait
it's like you know funny
you know funny sexual assault
again sir you just proved her point
even bianca does she is she
woke about everything man not when it
comes to getting her [ __ ] eaten
well i mean it wasn't like that was i
was the only one doing that
anyways it was he was you really don't
want to wake he was asleep you put him
[ __ ]
asleep but you know dozing
his resting is hot
fantastic and by the way i think that's
what um goodbye
jaguar wright was mad at comment about
you've got
hell howdy bianca and neil neil i'm a
big fan of your thoughts and analysis on
numerous topics but i'm still surprised
by your lack of support for soup
recently switched to a plant-based
eating and experimenting with soups open
a lot of doors for me in the kitchen
just wanted to speak up for the soup
lovers this uh yeah all right that's a
waste of time
um bianca you're awesome you're inside
into nuanced topics such as oral sex
is much needed and valued that being
said i would skip the wedding this year
so you know i'm still waiting for the
european updates if we
if there's a way i might go i gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here neil i feel
don't you just feel stifled a little bit
yeah but i'm not gonna go to [ __ ]
austria
well you're not invited next i got bad
news for you
i got news they heard the podcast i'm in
you're out
no i'm also here to get your perspective
on dating with
a chronic disease in my case it's
crohn's
it's chronic in my case it felt like the
it truly felt like in my case it's
crowned in the [ __ ] crohn's open the
crone curtain opens
um my days are filled with loose and
unpredictable bowel movements
damn am i destined for loneliness and or
weirdos only how soon should i
should i i don't want to bring it up
right away but i also feel weird
holding it back um this guy now that i
want to
[ __ ] on a guy from minnesota was it mark
mike from minnesota
got into this guy's email too uh and he
wrote the line
am i destined for loneliness and weirdos
only how soon should i spill the beans
or
toot the beans mark from minnesota
it's always a dollar what bad jokes you
[ __ ] i'll kill you okay
[ __ ] i'll sit on your face
how would neil deal how would bianca's
bianca [ __ ] with that
ellis senior this is midwest matt not to
be confused with
minnesota mike by the way if they're
not the same person i know this almost
seems like the same person's thing
and i'm and then i have another poop
joke i'm gonna double up
kansas kimberly we're on to you
uh i don't know enough about crohn's
disease
i don't think you have to no no i had a
friend with very bad chronic disease
okay
so it's basically it depends on what
stage you're in but it's
at the stage my friend was in um it's
just like a disease of the
gastric system right so at some point
his body just stopped recognizing
his colon and anus like
were part of his body so they stopped
sending it blood
started attacking it so it ends up it
ended up being like this is kind of
gross but
rotting meat inside of him so what's the
gross part
okay i love that what's
what's okay so they had to take it out
um so they had to take out his anus
colon
and just use his whatever the second one
is large intestine small intestine
and apparently by the way um cardi b and
and megan the stallion are making a new
song about this taking out some of this
and calling go ahead
so they take it out and they fix
you know a makeshift one with
unrecognizable anus and colin is the
name of the song
what's the acronym uh aoc
no you don't recognize ua
oh it's not good unrecognizable anus
calling
you it's all it's a bad rock yeah it's a
lot of scrabble it's a redraw
um so uh that made him
have to run to bathrooms couldn't have
certain things would just when i tell
you like right now
it would come out not eat it come out
but like let's say right you ate
something
david blaine where he would start eating
a slice of pizza
and the crust would be and then the end
of the pizza would come out of that
and he [ __ ] it over [ __ ] up that's
where this is
he could pull it he could pull his mouth
and
so imagine if right now all of a sudden
whatever you ate
a half hour ago or something jess was
like oh i got a [ __ ] and then
all you have to do is go down the stairs
to your bathroom and when you got there
this [ __ ] was already filled in your
pants just poop everywhere
it's poop life yeah there's a real poopy
thing yeah there's there
are there are so many things like that
that just a couple million people have
it
it's basically bad luck migraines
sorry you gotta lay down for nine hours
whitney used to have to go to the
hospital when he comes used to get such
bad migraines she had to go sit in the
hospital and get a drip
like it's [ __ ] bad and it's just one
of them like oh
yeah there's enough there's truly
nothing we can do
so crohn's are some things you can do
there's some like his got
basically kick-started by um that
that like really bad no no that acne
medicine accutane
really so accutane changes your dna it
changes your dna
so if you look at all the side effects
it can jolt
out things in your genetics so they
don't think if he took accutane
his crohn's would have been activated it
was from
he took accutane and then crohn's
developed and it's a side effect it can
like go and
poke out diseases that like lie dormant
accutane
my experience was i i wasn't an entitled
[ __ ] before
wow and then i took accutane thanks
accutane and it shook
it out and you're welcome america
so okay if you were dating girl that had
really loose bells couldn't always eat a
lot and
kind of maybe had to be close to a
bathroom and maybe there was
just to be perfectly honest when i go to
my friend's house just maybe like some
poop places but not a lot like speckles
of brown
in like all in the bathroom only in the
bathroom okay
okay um and this may be i'm sorry
crohn's people if i'm doing it like
not doing well but he had a very bad
case people i like it crohn's people but
what would you but she was great how
much would the
the stool be like couldn't really go
on long for i'd like to believe it
wouldn't but
i i saw somebody at a show last night
and they said that they moved in with
their girlfriend
and i go he goes yeah um
kovid made us we were like together for
a couple months and then kova just
basically just moved in
and i was like were you were you
would you have moved in with companies
like no we probably would have broken up
if not for covid and i was like yeah
it's like dating somebody's terminally
ill
you can't break out with her till the
funeral right
you can't if someone's terminally ill
you can't be like
right eight months it's too long for me
goodbye you just gotta ride it out
you gotta write out so with crohn's i i
like wait till she dies
yeah you can no i don't know i it would
be
i don't know i don't know if someone had
crohn's if i
if i how much did she [ __ ] on the first
couple days
honestly i i would never say ah if
someone [ __ ] your bed
would you be pissed goodbye goodbye
nice meeting you next letter hey
bankerton's and nilothy
nilathi it's tatiana and kristoff i
don't know who that is
rst l.a on some og [ __ ] we talk about
you like our actual friends
it is wild we are you just thicker neil
would say fatter and he'd be right
and blacker in terms of melanin not
stereotypical racial character
characteristics we're on your team binky
thank you
and you're wrong um we wanted to get
your
most up-to-date thoughts on dating in
the era of covet i can't believe you
wanted me to stay with a woman who shot
my bet
that is a [ __ ] first of all that's a
tough needle mattress up there i know
a cliff notes version of our dynamic we
are we are the best friends who
we are the best of friends who as a
jamaican puerto rican lady and a black
man raised in a white community when we
tend to talk about race and dating
almost exclusively like you guys
unlike you however we have no problems
hanging and banging
and never letting it affect our
friendship or working relationship as
we are roadies who live the rolling
stone lifestyle
i think that's literal i think they
literally are roadies
uh by the way the rolling stone
lifestyle is now punishable by law
uh while i don't know if you've heard
that next song but
it's not great while we were are very
good with the stay-at-home orders
portions of the quarantine for five plus
months
we are now thirsting for some sexual
activities
we've individually had success recently
on tinder with some people
we try to vet as best we can ask them
questions on how
safe they've been keeping etc but some
of our friends still think we should
remain at home
left to sexually fend for ourselves
those friends are in
committed relationships and have far
more access to sex than we are
uh but when you're hungry you gotta eat
right um
that's what bianca said when it came to
oral sex
what do you think but it was she wasn't
talking about her she was talking about
her
when i'm hungry you gotta eat uh what do
you think of dating hooking up with new
partners in these times do you think
it's best to live out the rest of 2020
thirsty and celibate
or do you think thoroughly vetting a new
sexual partner is okay if you're being
as safe as possible
uh during this time sorry about sorry
these are hard to read but
what's abraham bank banking thinking um
and what's neothon feeling fun
okay in my defense it was
very accepted it was very back in the
90s you could do that
next was on the on the charts it was
like it wasn't
fun it wasn't like i it was it wasn't
serious there wasn't like a light behind
me and i was a silhouette and i just
like
it's not your place to say what it was
okay
yeah i don't i i believe you look
that's all that matters uh where are you
one
on this i i can't do that [ __ ] i can't
[ __ ] someone and
like casually and be their friend and
keep [ __ ] i just haven't never done that
[Music]
so not even so covid what's your
it's amazing how little we talk about
this it's a we never talk about that i
think i got off but i don't
know okay great but uh no i i
just no i can't i can't be someone's
homie and [ __ ] them and then hang out
like best that's not what she's asked
she's asking how do you
oh how do you what are you doing during
covet what's your what's your new dick
new dick policy it's weird because it is
it sounds weird already go ahead no it's
weird because like
i don't know it's i'm actually not that
excited
do you know what i mean about like
usually when you're like just single and
stuff it's fine
you're dating blah blah blah it feels
normal but you have other things going
on so now that we all have like a little
bit less going on
i don't know you think oh let's fill it
in with companionship but it's like
i don't know it's like the vitality this
the vitality of pre-covert
upstating where is this it's a bit like
did i i don't know do you want to know
you yeah i don't know
yeah i don't know i don't know what
about you
uh i feel the same it's like kind of
listless
where you'll message somebody and then
you're like what am i where where am i
going with this
yeah goodbye
cry you've got mail hey guys
wow it got away from me medium listeners
i'm sorry
leaders are better podcasts than that
but not video
that's gonna get clipped hey guys medium
time listener
uh i actually find myself both liking
and disliking the guys
uh that you guys say on here which is
awfully damn refreshing thanks for that
yeah guys i don't know if you do this
you don't have to agree with everything
we say you just have to
all it has to do is stimulate
what you think yeah we don't have to
agree i don't want to agree with you i
want to
say things that you don't like but we
don't have to be canceled we don't have
to
not have discourse we don't have that
same energy
no i don't no we're wrong it's fine well
i wouldn't go that far
uh so i just want to interject we're
right for ourselves
but the thing is and i always say this
we literally we read our hate mail
yes and nobody does that if someone
proves us
in any convincing way that um
that [ __ ] what jimmy carr
answer jimmy you're on speaker on the
podcast jimmy
oh i can't believe my luck
it's a i mean you're a second time
you're the first
second time guest and what a what a
special day why
thank you thank you very much uh what
are you guys discussing american
politics
uh no we're discussing um
well we're discussing whether
fans of ours people listeners have to
agree with us
it's the thing is people think they have
to agree with everything you say now
or you're
argument people are cancelled yeah um
it's the
people say well i the internet it's an
echo chamber and then they only listen
to the stuff they agree with
they're crazy yes yes
uh you and i agree on on virtually
nothing
you and i jimmy carter yeah but i mean
you know your great quote on this
is is i don't agree with anyone about
everything
that's correct thank you for for telling
people even the former you
even the you know future you it's you
know of course it changes over time it's
you know
well you know what i've started thinking
of it as it's like the i'm a
living document like the constitution so
i will sometimes
hey guys we're going to amend we're
going to make an amendment
women you know what you can vote
go ahead and vote ladies how seriously
people take that constitution and they
go it's sacrosanct and you go you know
there are amendments in this
yes yes you that you're you can amend it
yeah you don't have to die for it you
just change it um
you're i want to speak to you i was
calling late night
i just played an outdoor arena in the uk
it was kind of okay
i guess were you how were people apart
people were in little kind of they were
almost like in little metal pens
oh okay i think there was a picture of
that over here
and what were the laughs like
and pretty good it was playable it was
like a playable you could hear them
heckling was i like people to join in
and shout stuff out when i'm playing
and that was a little bit tricky what
people were saying but you know
if you like i mean the outdoor arena
it's basically a field is what it is
yeah and how many people do you think
got infected
if you had to guess i think
i think i've got some blood on my hand
yeah 50.
hopefully nobody dies maybe a couple
ventilators
but it's worth it because you made 18
000 pounds
precisely my thought at some stage
we're not finding a vaccine to this
thing right
so what are we doing were we doing this
you want a show or not you want to hear
my
you want to hear my knock knock jokes or
don't you
oh i want to hear your number yeah so
well then you're
in the middle yeah which i happen to
love
uh you know i don't want to get in the
way of it would hey do me a favor when
you're listening to yourself
on the podcast i expect you i think
you'd be a fool not to masturbate
okay it would
hold on hold on i'm handing her over
hello how
how's neil been are you holding the the
speaking spatula
that was that was he was very mad at me
he was very tell her how great the
spatula was no the special was terrible
jimmy
back yeah it felt like
it felt like he'd been away on some kind
of conference and he decided this is how
this is how we communicate now with a
spatula are you okay
i'm okay jimmy i'm trying to get to
austria
for uh my cousin's wedding and everyone
tells me it's a bad idea
oh oh wow oh wow cause you haven't
mentioned that before
well i was thinking don't you know i
feel like i should go to this wedding i
feel so invested in this wedding in
austria
i was gonna do it
i was gonna do it i was gonna do a
layover in london
if i go and i mean
if you come please let me entertain you
on the way to almost certain death in
austria
well then you have to take me to st john
it's a demand
and uh wish
i'm very happy to very happy to take you
out and send you if you come to london
it's it's safe here it seems kind of all
right i think they have it under control
um to some degree people are wearing
masks people seem to be i don't know
do you get back to normal i think
school's the bag next week so that's
something
do you want do you have any like desire
to travel or are you good
at home he went to dubai are you into
dubai
uh yeah i went and did gigs in dubai i
played like an arena in dubai
um and then had to come they said i did
it specifically
but the tourist board paid for me to go
and it was meant to be some big hey
dubai is open come here on
holidays or vacation as you adora put it
and then they didn't open the air bridge
so i had to quarantine for 14 days for
my return
are you serious
do you buy it like the nicest shopping
mall i've ever been to
the whole country i mean the whole city
well basically the only bit i saw was a
massive shopping mall
but that's that's all it is right isn't
that all it is like it just seems
indoors and then you drive it's 140
degrees outside
and then it was 44 degrees which i've
got no problem with but it was
night time 44 degrees at night
that's 120 at night yeah that's a good
observation about the sun
they took my uh they took the high
temperature at the airport i went
dude everyone's hot what are you doing
what are you doing and you uh you by the
way i think
you should start a truth or campaign
that
that the moon generates as much heat as
the sun
i think now is the time the crazy thing
about that is it's not crazy enough for
those people no they would
we could get traction i hope we do from
this episode
look we're in the middle of letters
you've really this was like a great
guest spot you really showed your value
i feel like you're gonna
you're gonna build on sunday when you're
not recording i i genuinely keep doing
the show
i i adore it it's such a fun list i love
it thank you very much thanks buddy yeah
bless you i'll talk to you all right bye
i told you i know uh you weren't lying
people pretended people
think i don't know these people you
don't think i know ellen
well let's see that watch let's see that
watch
um medium
i just want to interject a procedural
point on the aoc video it's very
adorable that niels and
all his feels about women's
self-confidence being hijacked by beauty
companies
but i think you're kind of
misunderstanding what's going on here
with makeup tips
uh makeup tip videos are that are trying
to get you to buy [ __ ] generally have
some kind of language to the effect of
you can only get this flawless look with
this particular fantastic thing
uh hold on this woman sort of just goes
on and on
uh a video like this is more or less a
female equivalent of kind of shooting
the [ __ ]
and yeah for the most part i agree with
not wanting to know about your
personality and or likes dislikes while
you're in office
personality has a lot to do with what
kind of [ __ ] you really are
if i were to find out that some of the
some of the cops
in my town were obsessed with video
games and watched nothing but
80s action flicks miami viceroy runs i
would have concerns
so there is an advantage to knowing some
personal stuff about these guys
i'm not saying constantly but i have but
i also have the ability to not watch
them in the first place so yeah
so what she's saying is yeah aoc has
revealed herself as a
vain shallow person what no
but if you're saying you want to know
cops are ingesting
and believe is valid why is that shallow
what her video is just about what's
shallow about my beauty between
the all of it it's not
there's nothing there's nothing there's
no higher i don't think there's anything
negative inherently negative about that
video i think it's
vain how do you define vanity
no we know what the definition of vanity
is but you're putting it in a light
that's like
shallow vent like here's what i think i
think that
the whole movement of videos like that
are shallow and vain and the hope is
somebody an intelligent
person like alexandria
alexander yeah i kind of miffed it but i
i
i duffed it aoc is
above it but there's what's different
from saying your beauty routine then
going on youtube and trying to figure
out how to
assemble something or it's just an
instructional video i understand some
push
product and some do this again i if i
don't want
um chuck schumer on the money phone
because that's a [ __ ] thing that
people do
um on the internet
i think if you're an elected official
and uh some of the women look up to
you shouldn't do shallow vain dumb [ __ ]
and same for men i don't want to see
paul ryan i don't want to see the money
phone
i don't see planking i don't no no no
i wouldn't want to see ruth peter
ginsberg doing that
and and i also think people would be
like she's old
well when old women wear makeup why not
have her do it it's just
it's it's belittles her so whether it's
a movement or not
whether it's a movement or not by the
way anyone on the money phone
should be saying hello bankruptcy
goodbye because that's what's about to
happen to you
you've got man nianka since this has
come up a couple times i wanted a
clarification
oh this is great uh i wrote the long
piece
i wrote the piece long ago about al
franken working on a chris rock movie
yes
i heard about it first on the podcast
but as a real reporter veteran of ap
frontline etc i called senator franken
who confirmed himself that
he had indeed worked on the movie if
he'd said no comment or sorry i'm busy
right now or whatever i wouldn't have
written anything
so i'm not a snitch i still
okay then he goes because a one there's
nothing at all wrong with al working on
a movie with chris
two al franken was the main source of
the information not you and he was
speaking freely on the record
we were the original we were the
original source so we wouldn't have
whether he can yeah
that's exactly yeah my story didn't even
mention h f until the seventh paragraph
and i only mentioned it to prevent the
false impression that i'd swords
scored some sort of scoop yeah that's
your other mistake you mentioned in the
first three paragraphs so you don't
mention it at all you cox okay
uh with so much mistrust and
misunderstanding of the news media i
think it's helpful
i think it's unhelpful to act like we're
all waiting in the wings
for people to let slip unsource nonsense
and then pouncing reporters don't behave
that way
gossips do anyway love the pod
shake off these haters uh you don't have
to take this [ __ ] etc
uh i wrote back to him via email
as far as i recall friend you never
would have known he did a punch up with
chris if you hadn't heard about it on
the pod
and it and the article was definitely on
some quote he's back and working in
hollywood type [ __ ]
and i felt like somehow and it felt like
somehow that wasn't cool
even though as franken pointed out he
already was openly doing a podcast
um from my pov i do a thing with chris
i mention it on the pod you write about
it then it becomes a thing that those
guys have to answer for
then i look like a snitch to them feel
me i hit them with some vernacular
just not ideal as always i don't have to
take this [ __ ]
the haters are ever mutable and how dare
you use
frontline against me then he comes back
at me
i guess i felt like it was all very pro
frank and peace
because dude deserves at the very least
a hollywood comeback and not to use both
frontline and the new yorker
the two most fearsome weapons in the
liberal arsenal but i linked
in the second paragraph to the new york
article that shot down most of the
claims against al franken
but henceforth i'm strictly adhering to
the no snitching policy
you to avoid any unintentional snitch
fallout
which was never my intent thanks for
writing back my highest hope was that
you and banks might say on the air that
my email was too boring
and this succeeds that well i have some
good news for you my friend
it was a little bit boring um
now if you want to write about jimmy
carr doing an unscheduled
drop-in we loved it yeah with
knock yourself out just write a piece
about how much you love our podcast
yes you want to write a piece go write a
piece
but uh but you know no break in the news
you don't wanna
don't make someone comment on something
you heard
here if you have to call someone else
after listening to our podcast and ask
him something directly
you did it bad yes you did well again
he's basically saying that's what
gossip's doing it's like no that's what
tmz does
tmz breaks breaks lots of true stories
yeah
how they get the information is not
great because they get it from this
podcast
um i broke all that [ __ ] stuff you
know
everybody knows that um yeah
so uh so yeah don't
don't that the offer stands and uh
here's a funny ellen's an [ __ ] joke
everybody ready
yeah i'm not a joke um i had a
like timex watch that i got
on amazon for 15 bucks it's like gold
like the or
casio sorry like a gold casio yeah 13
it wasn't it was classic it was yeah you
saw it and
porsha who sounds like a porsche
um thank you mike mike if you're still
listening to this and alive
you're making a mistake um uh
she liked the watch she liked my watch
so i did
the thing that rich people do is i
bought her one
and gave it to her the next time i saw
her um
and porsha trying to be nice was like
looks to ellen and goes baby look neil
got me a watch and uh
ellen goes uh uh neil that's a nice
watch where'd you get it woolwarts
she's [ __ ] a funny person me
that's right funny mean great
exactly what our relationship to be what
i want it to be
and uh god bless her and then on the
other side
it's a long story but she's funny then
she said a second beat of funniness that
we don't need
goodbye final letter will you've got
mail
hey y'all lsdn er well that's nice
so i'm not so i know i'm codependent
alcoholic father mother extremely
intelligent but emotionally distant
i sort of wake up in the middle of a
[ __ ] up relationship
frankly most of my relationships uh have
been [ __ ] up one way or another
um i'm not entirely sure a deep and
meaningful relationship is in the cards
for me
i'm not sure i want that and i don't
trust myself
not to fall back into the bs cycle of
superman
to martyr to man scorned do you ever
feel like that
k-tao pal you want to read that
gippiensis afro-persian latina princess
um you know who loves that song who
um uh [ __ ] uh adele's all
oh she can't have it that's her jam
uh well yeah i very work i
very much worry about the problem with
being codependent
in relationships is you never know
if you're doing the right thing you
never know
i went from having no boundaries to
using boundaries
as a cudgel to keep people away
and you i'd never truly know
there's so many variables in a
relationship that it's impossible to
know
if had i been less boundary with that
person it might have worked
or more boundary with that person it
might have worked or i could have played
that
perfectly and they just and it still
wouldn't yeah
that's the you can play what if with
every relationship you've ever had
other than like absolute pieces of
garbage
but maybe even if they cheat i'm sure
people play
i know people play the game of like if i
but maybe if i just
sat on his face more he would
he'd still be here i mean it's something
look you got to keep it on the table you
got to be open to it
uh i you know i'm not codependent so
but i've dated code dependent people
like i'm pretty sure
and the ones i think are coded or the
ones that
they never like on the opposite end they
never
[Music]
they they don't they go against the
grain
they are like [ __ ] it up
unnecessarily it's like yo yo
this doesn't need to be this difficult
like there's nothing wrong
or there's nothing or like like i really
try not to be put on a pedestal i don't
like when a guy keeps doing that like
you're going to scare me away chill you
can't respect me this much
no it's it's just it's weird it's like
drink your bath water type of [ __ ]
but then it always flips and that's why
i'm like don't do that because that's
gonna
change so just like empower yourself
more
be a strong guy and chill out
like i don't like the too much because i
know that's gonna go
and then when that goes it's going to be
weird and then it'll come back it's like
i think that codependent relationships
i've been in or if someone that's has
codependent tendencies is the push-pull
ones where it's like stop wait now
and those ones are they're crazy to me
they're just like
you wanna like you want to like lucid
dream that person
and just like look at yourself you're
being insane
like look look at what we all see that's
you're so zoomed in
you can't tell like what are my
instincts right should i trust this
should i do this why now i feel like
it's like it's so much anxiety and
emote like weird childhood emotions that
come up that like
it's really hard for childhood emotions
i just feel like you're childlike well
essence
from their point of view yeah what
you're saying the problem with
any kind of mental illness that's not uh
codependency is not a mental analysis
it's
i don't know what the category is but i
feel like there's always something else
going on
yes but the problem with bipolar
borderline
any of the things is hey person
don't listen to yourself don't follow
your instincts your instincts
are sick they're sick
your instincts are poisonous they're
poison so
even when you're on medication you don't
know
if this the one of the bad instincts or
is this one of the
good ones right no [ __ ] there's no
you just don't know and that's like the
it's like jump
into the scary chasm yeah like you're
gonna make it i literally dated a guy
who's like it just i don't know why it
just feels like a matter of life or
death i'm like
in a relationship like everything was
going fine and it was just like
i was just like yo i'm so chill in a
relationship so it didn't it wasn't
coming from me
that's also what yeah that's that's a
codependent yeah that's codependency is
is
feeling like you need to perform up to a
certain standard and then
pushing pulling and then being like i
don't know
which voice to trust yes and it was just
like
i was like oh okay are you good like
that sounds insane to me yeah and you
will never
and i i don't know i don't my instinct
is
rush into sex right like just ever
they're all things that
there are no boundaries and then it's
like well no i gotta have boundaries
right it's it's put it's
so they got meetings every day don
i think it's just something you need to
like swallow just
plug your nose swell your vegetables
figure it out like but
you don't know what the vegetables are
you don't know there are
there are um so
the tenants of the the
relationship or just a decent
relationship is like don't rush into sex
be honest so then but your body is like
[ __ ] boundaries let's go
like isn't that romantic to not have
boundaries like we're [ __ ] crazy
no and it's true because i remember
being like dude you're gonna
scare me the [ __ ] away like chill yeah
i don't like what you're doing like we
ever there's
i think i remember i kept saying to him
like there's no rush
what's the raj what's the rush i don't
have if i'm not rushing like usually
it's the woman
if i'm like i'm not rushing you like
chill the [ __ ] out yeah and it's like
it's like this anxious clock
like it's like this is the train that
we're supposed to be on this is the love
train
we [ __ ] we fall in love there's no
boundaries like it's like
they think it's avatar like yeah avatar
that
that avatar that that ponytail [ __ ] the
ponytail
it's like which by the way
gross and like
ham fisted i mean they also called it in
obtainium so
whatever the writing of that movie is so
bad it was
it's it was a visual movie it was a
visual art yes project
yes um but yeah no that that weirded me
out because it's like
you have a trajectory that you think we
need to be on
i don't even know if you want to be on
it but we're on it and it's like slow
the [ __ ] down i don't how does one
breathe chill look at the reality
you have to train yourself work on yeah
it's you're it's caesar milan it's like
the piece of chicken's right here and
i want it so [ __ ] bad and you just
have to like
no we're not doing that we're doing
something else
um i don't it if i didn't know better i
would say we don't have to take the [ __ ]
i think we don't have to take this about
15 minutes over
having not taken it
that's right um that's it
look for us on clip
clips on on how neofeel and if you want
the full
thing although i think your cleavage is
covered by the mic which is a
huge oversight um but again well you
were smart not to say anything because
you can't say
now's the time move the mic so i can see
the middle of your breasts
yeah because then i would send that to
the hr which is me and i would have
rejected it
um thank you for listening we don't have
to take the [ __ ]
you don't either turn it off goodbye
the podcast is though you're live
yeah goodbye
tell me
[Music]
um